time now for the uplift at eight where
we share stories that will bring some
joy to your day to your day and ours as
well this morning you're going to see
how a father is being taught some
difficult moves by his six-year-old
daughter take a look
it is Michael
Jankowski practicing a cheer routine
with daughter Josie mom Roxanne recorded
the special moment you're doing a great
job a lot of flexibility for a man of
his age I recognize it Michael says when
he was younger he played football and
baseball never cheered but both Josie
and her sister Annabelle cheer
competitively which encouraged Michael
to join in so he could help with their
practice
and I never understood the cheerleading
world but once they got involved with it
and being a girl dad I was like gosh I
saw the joy in their eyes that I saw
when I played
when asked about her dad's performance
Josie said he did well she gave him a b
hey that's not bad he's passing pops you
gotta step your game up
a plus next time not bad I like that
bring in some Joy